today is a sacred day
obviously september 11th eight years ago
marked an attack on our nation that we
need to pay tribute to and recognize
and think about for a moment so i'm
going to ask you to join me in a moment
of silence
as we think about those who sacrifice
their lives and the friends that we had
and renew our resolve to understand evil
and never be silenced by such attacks
thank you very much the mission of the
kirby center like the college is
educational
and as we teach citizens about the
enduring principles of the constitution
the kirby center seeks to inspire
citizens including students scholars and
statesmen
to act worthy of the blessings of
liberty we welcome you to join us as we
continue this lecture series and move
around washington until we open our new
building across the street from this
building
in september two thousand ten bring a
friend
enjoy the fellowship become part of our
subculture
and next month our lecture will be on
friday october 2nd with heritage
foundations
matthew spalding who has a great book
coming out about first principles he's
also an adjunct professor with hillsdale
and will be at ebenezer's coffee house
around the corner from here
ambassador john bolton has pulled a
larger audience today than we usually
have
i encourage everybody to come on in
there's plenty of seats over here by the
way so just come on in and
grab a seat if you can um
ambassador bolton is a loyal friend a
principled strong leader for american
interests from both when he's both
inside the government
and outside the government working he's
an able-skilled lawyer
a diplomat he's been at senior levels in
the government at the justice department
at the state department at usaid
he's been at law firms around town at
senior levels he's served as
under secretary of state for arms
control and international security from
2001 to 2005.
then he served as the u.s permanent
representative to the united nations
very busy time very horrible place
horrible people but anyway he endured it
well
until uh 2006 when senate democrats and
at least one
irritating republican i can remember
kept him from serving any
longer in that post aei the american
enterprise institute is fortunate to
have him
as a senior fellow he wrote a compelling
insider tale about the policy battles
that if you haven't read you should pick
up
surrender is not an option and
today he's promised to grade president
obama's foreign policy as it's unfolded
so far
he will speak to us for about 30 minutes
he'll take questions
at the end we'll end at 8 45 so you can
go on your way before you ask questions
please identify yourself
and wait for the microphone please join
me in a warm welcome for john bolton
well jenny thank you very much for those
uh kind words of introduction and thanks
to all of you for uh
coming out as she said on a uh on a
rainy
friday in washington uh and i think it
is uh
important since it's the eighth
anniversary of
the attacks of 9 11 to take a look at
where
our foreign policy is and to judge
whether we're on a path to becoming
safer or on a path in the other
direction
and i think it's important in that
regard that we not
be intimidated by those who say that
criticism
of foreign policy uh or defense policy
that implies we're less safe as a
consequence of certain policies being
adopted
is somehow disloyal or unfair or
hyper partisan it is the essence of
uh political debate uh in the foreign
policy arena to judge whether the
interests of the united states are being
protected and advanced and when we
conclude
sadly that they're not i think it's our
responsibility
to speak out and those who try and say
that comparison with
levels of safety in the past is unfair
and appropriate i think have it
very badly wrong i think uh
it's it's also important to understand
that
uh for the last uh nearly eight months
now we've had a
very different kind of president uh than
we've had in the past
uh i call barack obama the first
post-american president
and by that i don't mean he's
anti-american at all
i think he recognizes that the united
states has
legitimate interests in the world of
course
so do 190 plus other nations have
legitimate interest
and he wants them to work out and that's
fine if you're an academic at some
university
but it's a very unusual view for
president of the united states
i think there's a lot of evidence about
why barack obama is
a post-american president but i'll try
and sum it up in just
one response to a question that he gave
in europe on
his trip a few months ago when a
reporter
said mr president a lot of people have
said have
commented on your unwillingness to
uh discuss american exceptionalism
uh the the view of america that your
predecessors have had that
uh the united states has a
has had a unique mission in world
history that it's a
city on a hill is uh the pilgrim uh
father said or a shining city on a hill
in ronald reagan's
uh amundation or a new jerusalem or any
of a variety of
of phrases that have been used to embody
the concept of american exceptionalism
and the reporter said mr president do
you believe in american exceptionalism
now this answer from the president is
extremely important to understand
both what he said in the first couple of
words and then what he said in the rest
of the sentence
he starts off by saying well yes i
believe in american exceptionalism
in the same way that the british believe
in british exceptionalism and the greeks
believe in greek exceptionalism
now let's take the first part of the
sentence he says i believe in american
exceptionalism so
for anybody else who wants to know
whether or not he does
or question it as i'm about to do he can
point to those first few words
but look at the remaining two clauses in
the sentence
where he goes on to say just as the
british people believe in british
exceptionalism and the greeks believe in
greek exceptionalism
there are 192 countries members of the
united nations i'm sure the president
could have gone on another 189
times with countries that believe in
their own exceptionalism and
it leads unmistakably to the conclusion
of course that if
everybody's exceptional then nobody's
exceptional
so you know we americans have this
belief in our exceptionalism but so did
the british and the greeks and the
burmese and the zimbabweans and the
ecuadorians
and everybody else and it's a it's a
nice thing to have a belief in
exceptionalism
but it reflects that he just
fundamentally doesn't think america
is any different from anyone else
and indeed it goes to the question i
think of how the president
sees his role in
not just our foreign policy but the
world as a whole and
he hasn't said this but there was an
unbelievably telling comment made by
newsweek editor evan thomas when the
president
spoke at the anniversary of the d-day
landings in normandy
and he said at the end of the quote
describing
president obama's speech evan thomas
said
i mean in a way obama's standing above
the country
above above the world
he's sort of god he's going to bring
all different sides together okay
so let's be clear the president didn't
say that about himself
but his loyal media followers were
saying it about him
and the i'll leave the god part out but
the part about standing above
country i think really sums up
a lot of what he thinks it's a question
of
working out america's legitimate
interest with everybody else's
legitimate interest and we'll see in a
couple of weeks
when the president chairs a meeting of
the security council at the head of
government level
how he approaches that this is the
classic standing above the world model
and i can tell you from the protocol the
security council
he'll say i re i give the floor to the
president of the republic of france
you know how gracious of him and the
republic of fra the president
uh sarkozy will say merci monsieur
president
and then he'll compliment him on how
wonderful he is and we'll have a couple
of hours of
barack obama being above the world
presiding over the security council now
there may be a few bumps in the road
here when libya which is on the security
council and the person of moammar
gadhafi
comes up to give the president a copy of
the green book and shake his hand
give him a little fraternal hug they may
have to decide how that's going to work
out
but this is again emblematic of a very
distinctive view
of america's role in the world and the
role of the president
it's not that other candidates for
president haven't
shared this view but it's the first
candidate for president who ever got
elected
if you go back for example to 1988
then vice president george bush said of
his democratic opponent
michael dukakis that governor dukakis
considers america to be another pleasant
country
on the united nations roll call
somewhere out there between
albania and zimbabwe that's a view
by governor dukakis i think not much
different from president
obama now vice president bush went on to
say
i see america as the leader a unique
nation with a special role in the world
that there's another definition of
uh or another description of american
exceptionalism
uh which i don't think we're going to
hear a lot of from the president so
when you look at the
policies that this administration
pursues in a in a wide variety of
circumstances
i think you have to start with the
understanding
of barack obama as the first
post-american
president and then a lot of other
aspects of his policies that are
otherwise
somewhat inexplicable come into play
and i think we're going to see this in a
in a wide variety of
contexts you know next week i am told at
a very
senior level administration officials
will be
meeting to decide whether to resign the
rome statute that created the
international criminal court
this was something that was negotiated
during the clinton administration
signed by president clinton even though
he never sent it to the senate to
to be ratified in the bush
administration we unsigned the treaty
because we thought it was
harmful not only to american interests
around the world but because it was a
fundamentally illegitimate effort
to create a prosecutorial and judicial
authority sort of floating out in
the international system i think there's
strong reason to believe that if this
administration
thinks that it can avoid a lot of
criticism
it will attempt to rejoin the
international criminal court
interestingly just as the prosecutor
is announcing that he's beginning to try
and uh decide whether he has
jurisdiction over
allegations of nato war crimes in
afghanistan
so a not a terribly propitious moment
for the administration to be thinking
about it but it shows the direction
that i think they'd like to go in if
they thought they could carry it off
um in a in a variety of uh more
traditional foreign policy contexts i
think we can see that the
administration really in in many senses
uh is is pursuing a policy that
i think can accurately be uh described
as neo-isolationist
and in that it harks back to a long
tradition within
the democratic party uh of
an unwillingness to be assertive in the
world in defense of american interests
and values and those of our friends and
allies
being a a baby boomer of course i well
recalled george mcgovern's acceptance
speech to the 1972 democratic
national convention at the height of
opposition to the vietnam war george
mcgovern's refrain them was
come home america come home america come
home from vietnam come home from a lot
of other places as well
that is an attitude that i think we see
playing out now not entirely formed i
wouldn't want to suggest that but
certainly
evolving in that direction let's start
with
the case of iraq where i think the
administration is determined
to pull out american forces along the
lines of the plan that was actually
decided at the end of the bush
administration without regard to the
internal situation inside iraq even as
american forces have pulled back from
prominent roles in the major urban areas
of iraq and violence has increased
the administration remains fixed on the
withdrawal schedule
because it's the withdrawal that matters
not the political stability
inside iraq and not the implications
of american withdrawal for the balance
of power in the persian gulf
region i think if anything we'll try and
see the administration
speed up the pace of withdrawal and i
think
that that pursuit of the
exit timetable without regard to the
political and military consequences on
the ground in iraq could have a very
harmful impact on our interest not only
in iraq but in
in the broader region as well we can see
in the case of afghanistan
that there's uh considerable debate
within the democratic party about
whether further troop increases
uh should be required uh now i i think
there's legitimate room for discussion
about what exactly our strategic
objectives are
in afghanistan and i for one am worried
about
a strategic objective that includes
making the country a stable
prosperous democratic society we're not
going to make afghanistan
into switzerland we're not even going to
make it into honduras
our strategic interest is making sure
the taliban and al qaeda don't use any
part of the country for
a base to launch terrorist attacks
elsewhere in the world
perfecting the afghan political system
is something we can safely leave
to the afghans but the notion that what
was once
the good war for the left of the
democratic party has now become
just another war that they'd uh that
they'd like to get out of
i think is going to be a very difficult
problem for the president to
wrestle with uh and and the path that he
takes is going to be significant because
in the case of
afghanistan the consequences of our
decisions there will have
important ramifications not necessarily
dispositive but important ramifications
in pakistan where i think our
interests are even more acute and where
the risks
the potential risks to the united states
and our friends around the world are
even greater
if radical islamists are able to create
conditions of chaos inside pakistan that
enables them to take control of the
government
they will immediately come into control
of a substantial arsenal of nuclear
weapons
which risks increased conflict on the
indian subcontinent
and also risks these weapons being
delivered to terrorist groups
that would be an immediate threat to us
worldwide so the issue in afghanistan
eight years after the attacks of 9 11 is
not simply preventing
al qaeda and taliban from returning to
their safe havens although that
remains a significant strategic
objective
but the issue has enlarged because of
the cross-border nature of taliban and
al-qaeda activities
to ensuring that pakistan's nuclear
capabilities don't fall into the wrong
hands and
how the administration handles that i
think remains very much
up in the air uh more broadly we
know that the administration believes
that its predecessor
didn't do enough negotiation
on issues like the proliferation of
weapons of mass destruction
and the administration has said uh
repeatedly starting with the inaugural
address
that it wants to hold out its hand to
countries like north korea
and iran in the hopes that they will
unclench their fist as the president
said
and enter into negotiation now this is
this is an interesting view of history
the bush administration
either directly negotiated or indirectly
negotiated with iran and north korea
for six and a half years so it's not
like negotiation
wasn't tried number one
number two negotiation is not a policy
negotiation is a technique negotiation
is
a way of achieving your objectives it
doesn't tell you what the objective is
and a lot of the talk about negotiation
that we've seen whether it's in the
context of iran or north korea or the
famous
reset button with moscow or a variety of
other contexts
doesn't really tell you what happens
after you shake hands and sit down at
the table
and i think that reflects a kind of
shallowness
in the administration's approach to
international affairs
that doesn't give much comfort for the
substantive outcome
that we hope uh that we hope to achieve
let's look at these problems of of north
korea and iran which along with pakistan
i think are the
most worrying aspects of the continuing
struggle against
proliferation of nuclear chemical and
biological weapons
in the case of north korea
we've seen the administration extend its
hand
and in response we've seen north korea
conducted second nuclear test
in april of this year we've seen further
launches of ballistic missiles we've
seen the effect of kidnapping
and incarceration of two american
reporters
and and just within the past few days
we've seen evidence that north korea is
allowing
flooding from dams inside north korea
into south korea
coupled with the typical north korean pr
campaign
uh to show that they actually want to
come back to negotiations
all of this uh demonstrates that
that they didn't you know they didn't
press the reset button in north korea
when barack obama was elected can you
imagine that
the north koreans are never going to be
talked out of their nuclear weapons
program they see the nuclear weapons
program as a trump card against the
united states against japan and south
korea
it's the ultimate protection for the
regime and it's a source of
revenue and leverage elsewhere in the
world particularly in
the middle east the north koreans are
happy to talk about their nuclear
weapons program they
have been successful over the years in
using negotiations to leverage
economic and political concessions from
their interlocutors they've even been
happy to pledge to give up nuclear
weapons by my count they've done it now
five times in the past 18 years the only
problem is that they never quite seem to
get around to
giving them up and uh we've just seen
again in the past
10 days the north koreans announcing
that you know actually they do have a
uranium enrichment program
despite the efforts of many in the
united states to say
to argue to the contrary even though
going back to
2002 we had very compelling evidence
that north korea had launched on a
production
scope procurement program for uranium
enrichment that they had benefited from
the proliferat proliferation network of
aq khan
and that they were engaged in extensive
nuclear cooperation
with syria building a reactor on the
banks of the euphrates river
obviously not because of that long
common cultural history they share with
syria
but because it's a very good place for
north korea to hide
evidence of its nuclear weapons program
from prying international eyes
so i think the odds favor the following
scenario
over the next year north korea is going
to agree to negotiate why not it's to
their advantage to do so it buys them
more time
it increases the possibility of further
economic and political benefits
and it will it will fundamentally
satisfy
the administration because they can say
we have brought north korea back to the
table
now that won't accomplish anything in
reducing the nuclear threat that north
korea poses
in northeast asia and around the world
but it will be enough
to take it off the table of of
concern in the media and thus for
purposes of this administration
solve the problem unfortunately
the threat of proliferation posed by
north korea
isn't only in northeast asia as i
mentioned it does extend to the middle
east where
north korea has been a major player over
the years
both in terms of nuclear cooperation and
in
its supply and work on ballistic missile
delivery systems for countries like
iran saddam hussein's iraq syria and
others
and here in the case of iran we have
another example
of how that extended hand from the obama
administration hasn't quite worked out
the way the administration anticipated
indeed there's now at least
anecdotal evidence that the
perception on the part of the regime in
tehran that the administration was so
eager for negotiations it would
overlook harsh steps internally
now seems to be borne out and we've seen
that in response to the administration's
extended hand
the the the muellers in tehran conducted
a grossly fraudulent
presidential election on june the 12th
and have spent
the months since then uh repressing
their opponents their adversaries and
dissidents uh with inside iran in fact
close observers of the situation in iran
think that
we're no longer in a struggle between
hardliners and moderates if there were
any moderates left
but that power is actually flowing away
from the ayatollahs
and toward the islamic revolutionary
guards course so that you're moving away
from a theological autocracy
toward a a a a theological military
dictatorship obviously since it's the
revolutionary guards corps that has
control of the nuclear weapons program
and control over principal funding for
iran's role as the central banker for
international terrorism
every prospect is that iran will grow
more dangerous
in the region and around the world as
time goes on
and so the administration's response
for the first eight months has been
we're going to try diplomacy with iran
unlike that bush administration that
wouldn't talk to its adversaries
we're going to talk to iran an
interesting idea
complicated only by the fact iran
wouldn't talk to them
and so now we hear the administration
saying well maybe the diplomacy isn't
going to work so we're going to rely on
sanctions
we're going to go after iran's
vulnerability
because of its lack of refining
capability for
petroleum products and we're really
going to squeeze them
now of course this is what the europeans
and the bush administration
thought they were doing for the last
seven years too it's why the security
council passed three sanctions
resolutions
which have essentially had no impact
whatever
on iran's ongoing nuclear weapons
program
so the idea that we're going to get
another sanctions resolution from the
security council isn't one that i think
realistic people would count on and you
know fortunately you can always count on
the russians and especially russian
foreign minister sergey lavrov who said
very clearly yesterday we're not going
to favor sanctions on iran and the
security council so
so much for that idea falling back to
plan b
the europeans after seven years of
hesitating seven years of being
unwilling to take strong steps now the
europeans are going to impose
strict sanctions well i'll buy you all
lunch on the day that happens
but even if the europeans finally step
up to the plate
other countries around the world are
going to take advantage of
their absence and we've already seen our
good friend hugo chavez in tehran
agreeing to substantial deliveries of
refined petroleum products to iran
and talking about nuclear cooperation
with iran something very important for
them given venezuela's
supplies of uranium in in the ground
that are now available to iran
so the fact is that the administration's
strategy
uh is in the process of failing just
eight months into the administration as
iran
every day goes grows closer to a nuclear
weapons capability
i've long felt that there were only
two alternatives to an iran with nuclear
weapons one was regime
change uh which we could have
facilitated had we done
almost anything in the bush
administration to support iranian
dissidents which we didn't
the opportunity the outrage
felt obviously across the country in
iran because of the fraudulent june 12
presidential election has now passed and
indeed i think the possibility of regime
change
in the short term in a in a period that
would affect the nuclear weapons program
is now essentially over because as i
said before
power is moving to the people with the
guns the irgc
and its uh and its affiliates so that
leaves the possibility of preemptive
military force against iran's nuclear
program this is an extraordinarily
unattractive option but it's on the
table because the other
option the other viable alternative iran
with nuclear weapons is even less
attractive
i can virtually guarantee the obama
administration will not do anything
in the military area which puts the
entire onus for this decision on
israel looking at past
practice israel has not hesitated when
it faced an existential threat it
destroyed saddam hussein's osurak
reactor outside of baghdad in 1981
in september of 2007 it destroyed that
north korean reactor in syria
so i think now for the next six nine
months the spotlight is very much going
to be on
israel and what the decision they make
this is going to come as a shock to the
obama administration
when it happens because the
administration has been pursuing an
essentially european policy with respect
to israel
based on the analysis that if you can
only solve the israeli-palestinian
problem
sweetness and light would break out in
the middle east and all of the other
issues we face
would become easier to solve including
iran's nuclear weapons program in fact
the analysis is very nearly the opposite
it's iran's continuing support
for terrorist groups like hamas
hezbollah terrorists in
afghanistan and iraq
as well as its pursuit of nuclear
weapons that's the principle source of
risk and instability
in the region as a whole but nonetheless
the administration continues to pressure
israel
for example to stop settlement activity
on the west bank
i think it's fair to say in terms of
time energy
rhetoric and diplomatic
effort that more time has been spent
pressuring israel to stop
building settlements than pressuring
iran to stop its nuclear weapons program
so
you you can see the direction that
that's uh that that's going in
uh there there are a whole host of
issues that we could cover here the
issue of how to deal with russia and the
so-called reset button as i mentioned
how to deal with
china an enormous problem how to deal
with hugo chavez in this hemisphere
where the administration has gone wrong
in
uh its uh the the steps it's taken that
have i think
gravely impaired our capability to
gather human intelligence around the
world by
uh declassifying hundreds of pages of
documents that now explain
what our interrogation techniques are
what we do
what we don't do what's been successful
all of which i'm sure went right into
al-qaeda training manuals
we've seen the administration at a time
of the the grossest profligacy
of domestic spending in our history uh
imposing essentially a ceiling on the
defense department
and a zero-sum analysis that wherever
expenditures increase in the defense
budget there have
to be offsetting reductions while we're
spending whatever the number is now 800
billion dollars
in stimulus on domestic plans that
include every idea
apparently that's ever been in a file
cabinet in a bureaucracy in washington
we're hesitating and pulling back on
missile defense
we're not making decisions on new
generations of
weapon systems canceling the f-22 unable
to decide on the next
generation aerial refueling tanker and
the list goes on and on
i tell you this is a very depressing
record to date in mere eight months
and i don't see any prospect that it's
going to improve
even where the obama administration has
pursued policies
that have looked somewhat like the
previous administration or that conform
to what in my view is the right approach
to defending american interest around
the world it has done so
grudgingly and with the clear
implication that absent political
uh constraints it would have done
something different
so i understand why americans are
concerned about our
economy why we want to get back on the
road to recovery
i understand any new president is going
to have his own domestic priorities
uh in this case restructuring our health
care system
but let's be clear our adversaries
around the world
are not standing idly by while we debate
these domestic issues
our focus on whether or not there should
be a public
insurance option in health care is a
very important issue
but fundamentally people like kim
jong-il don't care
where we come out on it although i
suspect he favors the public option
we we need a president who's going to
provide us with leadership
uh in international affairs not a
president who believes
that america should come home but
believes that the best place to defend
our interest
is overseas rather than in the streets
of america thank you very much
so so as jenny said i'd be happy to
answer questions
and i think there are microphones out in
the audience if you could raise your
hand and then just identify yourself
uh when the microphone comes to yes sir
right right here
hi my name is can you is it on yeah
my name is terry cook and first of all i
was wondering
where your teleprompter set up
because i noticed that you didn't you
were looking but
anyway your first point i think it was
very telling
and if you discount
that this president if you stop assuming
that
the president is doing what you would
want to do
protect american interests and say
well america is not exceptional it's not
a big priority
to protect america then if you take that
next step
what would you think or project
that his mission that he might think his
mission
as the president might be well you know
i i think
uh the the the corollary to the idea
that
america is not an exceptional country is
that the voices of others
whether they be friends or adversaries
have a
should have a greater weight in
uh determining what the outcome should
be
now i i've always thought an american
president should be an aggressive
advocate of our interest that doesn't
mean that he ignores
friends and allies like like like like a
good
lawyer he doesn't ignore the reality
that
that he deals in and recognizes that you
can't always get
everything that you want that there have
to be um
at times concessions and accommodations
but at least you understand
what your objective is if your objective
is
not to offend anybody to try and have
everybody get a little piece sort of
like you know elementary school
field day where every third grader gets
a medal if if that's your idea of
the proper uh structuring of the
international environment then then then
i think we're going to be in difficulty
and i'll just give you a contemporary
example of how i think this plays out
and that is the recent decision
by the government of scotland or the
government of the united kingdom you can
take your pick
where the decision was made to release
the convicted
uh bomber of pan am 103
al mcgrahy to release him to libya now
this is a situation where of the 270
people who were murdered by this
terrorist 189 were americans many of
them
university students on their way home in
december of 1988 to celebrate christmas
with their families
the the decision uh to turn
mcgrahy over to scottish jurisdiction
was accomplished by an agreement the u.s
the uk and libya reached where
we agreed that the prosecution would be
under scottish law
since the plane fell on lockerbie in
scotland
and on the condition that the libyans
insisted that the prosecution not
constitute
an attack on the interest of the libyan
state
uh which many people interpreted as
meaning the prosecutor should prosecute
mcgraw he and the other person who was
turned over
and not trying to prove gaddafi was
responsible for the decision to blow the
plane out of the sky number one
and number two by the u.s agreeing that
the prosecution would be under scottish
law
that meant that the maximum penalty the
defendants could receive would be life
in prison in other words the u.s was
giving up the option for the death
penalty
now many people thought that was a
reasonable deal at the time because we
got mcgrachy into custody and
i don't question that for present
purposes i simply use it to show
that that guy wouldn't have been in a
scottish jail but
for american agreement and in fact at
the time
one of the proposals was that if mcgraw
he
was convicted he would he would serve
time in a u.n
prison and the victims of the families
in this country said
no way if he if he is convicted he we
want him to serve
in a scottish jail not a u.n prison not
a libyan jail
and and that was agreed to as well so my
point by reciting this history is the
united states
and the victims families in particular
have a huge interest
in the status of mcgraw
and it's inconceivable to me
at a time of global obama mania
and with our closest ally in the whole
world
that if the president hadn't said to
gordon brown you cannot allow this man
to be released
that the british would have allowed him
to go it's inconceivable to me
if the president felt strongly about it
and i think what happened
was that we probably made a pro-forma
objection
but the president didn't want to offend
anybody didn't want to offend the
libyans that might offend other people
in the middle east
didn't want to press the british
probably didn't care that much about it
honestly
probably didn't care that probably more
concerned about health care reform
than the fate of el mcgrahy that is an
example
of being post-american
well why should you be so concerned
about the feelings
of the families of 189
american victims 11 scotsmen were killed
on the ground when the plane crashed and
the scottish government decided they
wanted to show
compassion for mcgraw-hill well you know
it all works out doesn't it
that this this is not what an american
president should do
and and uh senator lautenberg of new
jersey has called for a congressional
investigation he's written senator kerry
the chairman of the senate foreign
relations committee
i think we ought to have it and have it
soon and find out
what did the president know and what did
he do about it
yes sir in the back
howard segermark uh john was it a good
idea to send clinton to north korea
are there adverse effects and what would
you have done yeah i didn't think it was
a good idea
uh i thought that uh
even if as the two reporters have
admitted
they were briefly inside north korea
that was no warrant for the north
koreans to
grab them hold them sentence them to 10
or 12 years at hard labor
they should have been given a slap on
the wrist and they should have been sent
back
out of the country so the north korean
decision to seize these two reporters
was a was to me was an act of state
terrorism
and with a clear political agenda this
wasn't a simple law enforcement border
immigration
customs matter now we've had a policy in
this country for decades
bipartisan policy against negotiating
with terrorists and the reason we've had
that policy is we don't want to do
anything
that increases the incentives for
terrorists to grab americans and hold
them
hostage i think that is a sensible
policy
obviously part of the leverage that
north korea or
terrorist group has over us is the
absolutely understandable human
compassion we feel for the americans who
are being
incarcerated but a president has a
responsibility while trying to free
those who have been captured
not to endanger other americans more in
the future
and by getting former president clinton
to go to north korea
i think that that's exactly the message
that we were sending quite apart from
the legitimacy that it
gave kim jong-il you may have thought
and i may have thought that president
clinton looked decidedly unhappy
standing there next to kim jong-il
but but for pr purposes
there he was not quite as good as
madeleine albright clinking champagne
glasses with kim jong-il as she did in
2000
but good enough for government work in
this case
we now see the consequences or at least
it follows from
from that what what's happened in other
situations
senator webb goes to burma in order to
get out the american who was
convicted of trying to visit aung san
soo chi
i think the burmese who have their own
collaboration with north korea
at least on conventional weapons and
secretary clinton herself even said
perhaps in the nuclear field
saw the benefit and applied it uh very
soon thereafter we've got
three american backpackers who for
reasons best known to them were hiking
in the border area between iraq and iran
grabbed by iranian authorities they're
now in tehran
and and being used as bargaining chips
along with other americans that the
iranians have held incommunicado for
some time
so so now we're in a situation where you
have to ask yourself
what american is not important enough
for bill clinton to go and rescue
if their captors demand that that's the
price of getting it
as i say i think an american president
has a responsibility to get our people
out of jeopardy whether they were
foolish and getting themselves in
trouble or whether
it was not their fault at all but that
responsibility
has to be exercised in a way that
doesn't increase
uh jeopardy for the the millions of
other americans who travel abroad every
year as well
yes sir
my name is bob schnabel
i have an interest in honduras
and the support that our government has
provided to their deposed president
in spite of the fact that he was in the
process of
disregarding their constitution
can you grade the president's uh efforts
in that
respect yeah f no question about it i
mean this this is this is a disgrace for
the united states
this is an absolute disgrace uh
the the honduran constitution like like
constitutions in many latin american
countries provides
one term for their president and the
reason for that is their historical
concern about
cardios strong men men on white horses
getting themselves uh elected and then
deciding this is a pretty good deal they
don't want to leave
and what zelaya was trying to do was
through a referendum mechanism and
otherwise
changed the constitution impermissibly
so that he could
remain in power i don't think we know uh
fully how much hugo chavez was
supporting this effort but i don't think
there's any doubt
that he was as he has in other countries
bolivia
ecuador peru as he tried to interfere in
the recount
in the most recent mexican presidential
election
and the other legitimate authorities in
honduras
tried to react to what was going on
it is surely the strangest military coup
in the world
where the supreme court orders the
military to carry it out the national
congress approves
and the next person in line
constitutionally to succeed
the president when a vacancy occurs
takes office
and yet with with no hesitation that i
could tell
we were right there with danny ortega of
nicaragua and hugo chavez and fidel
castro
condemning this effort by the honduran
people and government to to avoid having
another hugo chavez put in power there
even more remarkable than that is that
most recently in
in announcing cut-offs of foreign
assistance to what is after all the
second poorest country in the western
hemisphere
the state department indicated it might
not even respect the outcome of a free
and fair election later this fall where
neither zelion or micheletti would
compete just incredible that that we've
taken
this this kind of uh position you can
only
ascribe it to a a rigid kind of ideology
that i think reflects uh very poorly on
the united states it sends a terrible
signal to other allies around the world
it sends a terrible signal to the
government of colombia for example
which is criticized by some on the left
in this country for
abuses by civil militias that are
opposing the
narco terrorists who run much of the
country even though those narco
terrorists are in league with hugo
chavez being supplied by weapons their
funding comes from the
sale of illegal drugs you know when you
kick around
a tiny country like honduras uh
in the way that we have i i i think it
again leads people to say
that uh that you have to be careful of
having a friend in washington
and in the back there
yeah my name is bruce kaufman um you
spoke early about
the obama administration at some point
hoping to get back under the
jurisdiction of the international
criminal court
and that there might be some criticism
that wouldn't one of the criticisms to
the extent that that would put
american citizens under the jurisdiction
of an international court
wouldn't one of the criticisms be that
it's unconstitutional
and second thing is this another example
of post-america
well i i think that it i think is an
example of post-americanism and i think
it's part of a long
series of efforts by by
people who style themselves as advocates
of international human rights to try and
constrain the united states
you know we we have the best program
in the world bar none for training
people in our military to obey the laws
of war
we have
considerable enforcement capability when
our soldiers
for for unacceptable reasons violate
our laws their training and our doctrine
we don't hesitate to enforce these
prohibitions
we have i would be happy to hold up the
american record against
any other country in the world it is
true that sometimes
our soldiers do commit
crimes that violate our laws a little
secret here
our country is made up of human beings
who are imperfect
but but we prosecute them and and and we
have nothing to be ashamed of so the
notion that we need to subscribe to an
international criminal court
uh to help us do it right i i think is
just fundamentally
wrong but it's not untypical of a view
that our democratic institutions by and
large are inadequate to the task
of uh of governing ourselves
as a people and it's because of a
i think a very uh widespread view that
that that we need broader international
norms
to govern our conduct that our decisions
alone
through our elected representatives are
not enough so i'll give you an example
from just within about the past
four or five weeks you know we have in
this country a statute called the
americans with disabilities act it is
our way of dealing with
citizens with disabilities and and
protecting them against
discrimination you can agree or disagree
with this or that aspect of it
i'm simply saying we have in congress at
the federal level
had a public debate on it we've had
votes and that's that's the outcome of
our constitutional system
four or five weeks ago susan rice the
ambassador to the u.n
and representatives from the white house
signed a convention in new york
that's an international convention on
people with disabilities
now i can't myself
understand what the international policy
implication of people with disability
is it may be on international airplane
flights and things like that there are
there are things that uh that that
require addressing and if so so be it
but that's not what this convention says
it's part of a long line of conventions
like
the convention on the rights of the
child with a convention on the
elimination of all forms of
discrimination against women and a
series of others
that basically say well you know it's
true in the united states you've debated
these issues and
you've come to your own conclusion but
but you need international norms
that you can continue to advance toward
and i i just i i think this
propensity to take decision making
out of the hands of elected
representatives and put them in the
hands of diplomats first
who then create treaties that are
brought back and presented to the senate
for ratification is a very
dangerous precedent but i think we're
going to see a lot more of it
in this administration once they fix our
health care system and can turn to other
things
you're going to see more and more of
this kind of activity i think it's a
it's a considerable
risk to us i think it betrays a lack of
faith in
the strength and validity of our
constitutional structures and i think
it's something we should be more
concerned about
yes sir down here
thank you uh scott shulman thank you uh
for being here today
i got a hundred questions but
how how could you keep your sanity
doing what you did at the u.n
and secondly what do you see
as ways that maybe going forward
as a country we can get back to where we
were
well i think i think the uh i like to
say
you know if if if americans uh
could have just joined me in the u.s
mission at the u.n
for 30 days and wandered the hall with
us and gone to the meetings
and and just done what we do in new york
for 30 days
you would have an amazing view world
countrywide of the united nations system
jenny was up there for for a couple of
weeks well some some people might not
take 30 days but
um you know you you have to uh i think
you have to you have to view it in that
sense and i i thought it was
important that uh that that
we changed the idea at the u.n that the
united states was just a well-bred
doormat
and that you know we were we were
prepared to speak up for our interests
say there's something shocking isn't it
um and and you know honestly
i think most of the other diplomats
appreciated that because they wanted to
know
what we really thought and they may not
agree
with it but it was a lot better to know
it and and to deal with it straight up
uh in in terms of what to do about the
country as a whole i i think we
i know we're not in a partisan
environment here but i think we need to
have a one-term
president that's the first thing to do
to uh to change it because
um you know the the there's nobody else
in the world that's going to stand up
for american interest if we don't
and uh when you have if my analysis is
right and this is a post-american
president we've got
40 months to go where i think a lot of
difficulties are going to
are going to develop and that aren't
going to be cured
automatically simply by electing another
president these budget decisions that
are being made in the pentagon the
cancellation of weapon systems
uh the deterioration of our intelligence
gathering capability
these these decisions will cause
problems that will take years to fix
uh and uh and and and i i think the we
we can only hope that
uh that our adversaries uh are not in a
position
uh to take advantage of the weaknesses
that we're developing
yeah over here hang on a second
sure you you've talked skeptically about
the value of uh
sanctions uh and skeptically about
military force what do you think the
pros and cons are
of a militarily enforced uh blockade
of refined oil plot products as opposed
to simply sanctions
i know that some people would say that's
an act of war but how would you evaluate
the pros and cons of that
compared to the alternatives well if uh
if the europeans were willing uh and i
wouldn't hold my breath on that
um uh you know you could have we could
impose
a military blockade ourselves but but
presumably
uh you would want others to to join in
the fact is you're never going to get a
security council resolution that
endorses that
you're not even going to get the
sanctions to begin with out of the
security council let alone an
authorization to use force
so that means that it would simply be by
the say-so
in effect of whatever countries
participated in
uh the military activity and i don't
think i can't think of a country today
that would do that i cannot believe this
administration would do it on its own
i think what they're going to do what
i'm more worried about
is given the the failure of their policy
on iran which which simply becomes more
evident with every passing day that they
will find a way to accept
the iranian nuclear program continuing
under the guise that it is
frozen and declare that as a victory and
then go on and try and reform some
other sector of our domestic economy
when the fact is that's an utterly
unverifiable commitment or agreement by
the iranians and it simply means they
will continue toward their breakout
capability with nuclear weapons
that's why i thought i would have said
strict sanctions like like banning the
importation of refined petroleum
products
was a good idea about six years ago but
we wasted that period of time in the
bush administration allowing our friends
in europe
to try everything in their imagination
to convince the iranians to give up
their uranium enrichment program which
the iranians have made clear over and
over again they're just not going to do
yes ma'am
hi can you speak a bit about what the
administration's seeming hesitancy on
missile defense means for our
relationship with nato allies in
central eastern europe yeah i think many
people in the administration just don't
believe missile defense
will work number one they've never
believed that uh despite the continuing
growing body of evidence that we can
make it work
i think the missile defense has become
so neuralgic with the russians that it's
part of the reset button idea that we
can
you know will cooperate with the
russians on their concerns on missile
defense and that'll make the russians
help us on iran i mean it's it's this is
like kindergarten kind of
logic but i think that's part of it and
i think the uh
you know the irony here is that where
many in nato uh
at the time we were trying to get out of
the abm treaty of 1972 believed that
our pursuit of missile defense would be
strategically destabilizing now
understand why we were right all along
and that the threat from rogue states
with limited numbers of
nuclear weapons is precisely what
missile defense should guard against
we've now gotten all the europeans on
board for that we've gotten the czech
republican
and poland to agree to put uh sightings
for
for radars and missiles in their
countries and now we're going to pull
the rug out from under them and again
it's going to lead
people all over the world to say what is
the
what is the advantage of signing on with
the americans here it will cause
enormous concern in
eastern europe about the
administration's willingness to stand up
to continued russian belligerence which
i think is the only way you can describe
their policy
after all if you go back to august of
2008
when the russians invaded georgia the
first reaction of candidate obama
was to call on both sides to exercise
restraint
that's balance this is this is my you
know above the world president bounce
georgia now you exercise restraint and
russia
you exercise restraint so i'm
even-handed right and that this is uh if
i were an eastern european i'd be very
worried yes sir
john gordon uh i'm a little bit uh
puzzled by an apparent para paradox
between
a neo-isolationist
attitude on the part of the
administration and yet their willingness
to acquiesce to control
from various foreign bodies like the ice
ice international criminal court and so
on and i just
i guess i'm wondering what motivates
them is that uh
is it a loyalty to their voting
constituency is it a competition for
resources between
international interests and domestic
interests
or is it just an ideological uh bent
that cannot be changed
well i think i think in part it's uh uh
it's a reflection of deep-seated
uh discomfort with american power
and the the way that american power has
been used around the world even let's go
back to the case of afghanistan the
so-called good
war well now they've got a president
they've got majorities in both houses of
congress and the good war doesn't look
so good to them that
that uh you know you then have to ask
what
what what where is the case where we use
american force to defend
our interest if first you said it was
afghanistan now it's not afghanistan
where exactly is it and and i think
that's that's a major part of the
problem
i think also it is a
philosophical reflection of a view
widely held in europe
that the problems europe faced in the
20th century
were caused by national sovereignties
and the answer for many people in europe
to the threat posed by national
sovereignty is
abolishing national sovereignty so many
on the european left in particular over
the past decades have been
reducing their national autonomy
shoveling authority toward
brussels in the in the form of the
european union and its bureaucracy
and i think a lot of europeans would
like to shovel a little of our
sovereignty toward international
institutions as well
so if you don't feel comfortable with
american power to begin with
uh locking it in to institutions that
can constrain it
uh really is a way of protecting us
against ourselves in their views so
if you if you um if you followed that
if you go back to uh the war in the
balkans for
example in the late 1990s the u.n
secretary general at the time kofi annan
said
that security council authorization is
required it's the only way you can
legitimately exercise
force in the world and i think there are
a lot of people in europe who believe
that i think there are a lot of people
on the american left who believe it
they're just afraid to say it
but if if you got people actually to
believe that obviously we would be
dramatically constrained in what we
could
do to protect our own interests around
the world and the more treaties we have
the lower our levels of nuclear weapons
that we agree with the russians
which the administration is eagerly
pursuing hopes to have a treaty by the
end of this year
the less able we are to cause trouble
now we know a lot of other people in the
world agree with that but i think that
instinct not that they would ever say it
but that
discomfort with american strength is
is evident in a lot of places in this
country too
might take just one more question if i
could yes sir over here
doug wisey can you see a connection in
foreign policy with our
government's stance vis-a-vis
the situation in mexico with the drug
cartel
violence and now they're trying to blame
it upon
us and the transport of
weapons across the border i foresee a
further attack upon our second amendment
rights in all this myself
yeah now i think i think you're quite
right to be concerned and
and the idea that that the drug cartels
and the violence in mexico is because
they're buying guns from the united
states as opposed to the hundreds of
other places around the world they could
buy them
is really fairly remarkable and
you know it harkens back to gene
kirkpatrick's
famous speech at the 1984 republican
national convention
where she talked it was in dallas but
the democrats had met previously in
san francisco speaker pelosi and
gene talked about the san francisco
democrats
and their views and and she said they
always blame america first
and here was another example in the
mexican
drug situation
because there's no doubt that that a lot
of the gun control groups in this
country
frustrated that their inability to get
the system they want at the federal and
state level
have tried to internationalize the
effort this is another one of these
norming exercises where they want to get
an international
treaty that every other country in the
world agrees to even though half of them
agree to it and then ignore it but they
would bring that back to the senate and
say we don't want the u.s to be isolated
you need to pass this
and and and we would have gun control
brought in indirectly
you know one of the one of the uh one of
the most controversial things i said
when i was in the bush administration
was in 2001 at one of these u.n
conferences on it was called on small
arms and light weapons
where i said the united states is not
going to agree to any international
convention
that if an act that is positive law in
our country would violate our
constitution
well i mean you would have thought i had
said something really terrible
because they knew exactly what that
meant that we weren't going to
permit infringement on second amendment
rights or or any others for that matter
and i think that's why this issue of
sovereignty and the view of what
what why it's legitimate for us to
defend what to me is the essence of
sovereignty which is self-government in
the united states
people who say you need to share
sovereignty with international
organizations or other countries
are really saying americans have too
much control over their own government
and they need to give some of it up i'm
humbly of the view we don't have enough
control over our own government i don't
want to give up what little we have
so this is uh uh th this is i think
emblematic of a strain of thought in
american life and i think it's one that
is very nearly controlling in the obama
administration
thanks again thank you all very much
you